hey guys I'm riding right hi I'm Lauren
god rot Lauren back to the channel and
she just got a text message about a
video that she has to watch on YouTube
no I literally got it like two minutes
ago and I was yeah hey Ryan look at this
video we should watch this
oh yeah [ __ ] totally forgot mentioned
the name of the video alternative model
has her anus cast in bronze
that's her but I don't understand huh
well I'm sure we'll find out the video
it's my riot TV don't know what they do
I'm here to meet a fellow called Magnus
to get my crown star turned into a
bronze
I do like experience new things even if
they're weird we first started selling
edible anuses 10 to 15 years ago 15
years ago we'll cover you up
so that just Uranus is showing right
what is a very smooth sculpture based on
the cast of and they are real owners we
thought this is really close it gets
messy I
[Music]
having made chocolate illnesses now for
the affair while we've moved in trainees
get change then it's behind the screen
please
and these available to anybody who wants
their own copy of someone else's I'm
ready
bringing the patient in terms of the
casting process of the illness
I think in general individuals are a
little bit worried don't find it very
difficult very quickly then their
concerns disappear and then it can be
quite an enjoyable occasion this is the
weirdest yoga position ever
it's like [ __ ] important skip pass it's
a little bit of a news event and I think
it's something that you might person is
being cast maybe remember for a long
well you know folks some reason person
next you and talk about your anus custom
I'd be fairly sure that he or she is
never had that experience probably about
a part a little three cheeks okay okay
I ever tried to do a cast of bananas I
tried to do my own and wait until my
misses and gone out and the Son of God
the school I went in the kitchen I mixed
up the allergen it
I like poured it into me bum well you
know I took the trousers often put me
knees either side I made probably stuff
in his bum and they all ran past me and
that symptom it faced don't move
anything there yeah I know it was great
done there was some interesting failures
you can't get out your pubic is oh it's
six-figures you can't mix it with warm
stuff if you mix it with warm water
it comes off far too quickly now I'm
just what I'm doing is just sort of
making sure it gets in there that's it
you keep putting your bum apart that's
good yes yes please
okay that's gonna come out
[Music]
he's too real man Patrick Moore would
have been good but he's dead perhaps and
Patrick rolls their diners that would be
my jury - the anus of a corpse and that
would be a real tribute to Patrick Moore
I think I don't know doesn't matter it's
as hard as it will ever be so this is
the time to take it apart it's the
moment of Revelation that's in the Bible
isn't it okay so it's four weeks since I
saw my bum chum Magnus and I just got
this Wow it's the bronze Brown star and
I'm gonna display it on my mantle
I do know their holders coffee cups we
thought about putting one in the bottom
of a coffee cup so that when you drop
your coffee it's just in the video not
like three times
ah yeah it's pretty awesome actually he
is awesome he's a dude who I'm like wow
I could see Johnny Depp playing you one
day but he's he was so sincere I know
but that's the best part of it because
if he was weird about it like if he was
like creepy or parent then it would have
made that a weird experience but he was
sleek actually pretty normal about it
and kinda makes jokes kind of making fun
of the silliness of it
it's like he's a little bit of where
it's silly when he's like talking about
how she laughs it changes I know hey
that girl
Rayna Tara was being a really good sport
about it oh she was I feel like this was
like hey do you want to go do this for
our TV show or YouTube channel or
whatever this is I want to not judge and
actually try to understand why someone
would want to do that yeah like weird a
couple yeah okay I could see how if you
found out about it but you're like
uh-huh that might be interesting I could
see someone doing it just for fun right
it seems like he has clients that are
actually doing it for like some serious
like personal thing
it's hard for me to tell Magnus is the
most interesting part of this video to
me because of this the way is like
philosophy towards this is like so many
people will find this to be such a silly
thing I'm sure that's why it's a big
video but he's so like genuine and if I
could he's like oh we can make them
chopstick holders or like put them in
the bottom of a coffee mug or that
they've been selling anus chocolates for
in what 10 years is that yeah
anus chocolates I mean honestly if I saw
a box of chocolates like that I probably
would know what it was until somebody
said something I'd be like oh that does
it how would you react if he found out
it was sculpted from someone's actual
butthole I would be like that's super
weird
would you still eat it yeah it's
chocolate but it looks like poop
no doesn't like poop it looks like a
bubble I know but when it's chocolate it
looks like a butthole that's covered in
poop right yeah I cannot eat chocolate
if I'm like I'm gonna immediately think
of someone [ __ ] what is the green stuff
he's putting on her but have you ever
gone to the dentist when they take a
mold of your teeth it's like a mixture
that's kind of gummy and then it hardens
and then you can make a mold out of that
Wow I might do it for fun we would have
to go to London or you it's worth the
plane ticket so I could come back and
make a few people laugh I was really
interesting I'm actually glad I watched
this cuz it's a fun fact to know it
actually was really interesting like I
feel like the way that they did it like
the way that they filmed this little
clip yeah it was nicely done it wasn't
like in a weird jokey way and or in a
pervy way it was kind of an an
educational like there's yeah out there
that does this and it wasn't shot either
through a judgmental way like we're
trying to convey like a horrible thing
or yeah something like like I'm this
woman I'm gonna go try this let's go
yeah I have like that fun quirky music
to it that is pretty interesting it's
interesting you know that people like
that if you do I'm not judging in the
talkin why not why not I'm sure there's
some people have a serious sentimental
meaning to it like who worshiped this
guy seems like he worships the anus
I guess he talks about a fat guy's
corpse and says that would be as dreamy
yeah who is that guy
I don't know Patrick Moore
anybody knows who that is let us know
yeah but don't follow it up by calling
us an idiot right please cuz that's just
never heard of he's dead too so thanks
Lord for who your boyfriend yeah but now
that people know that's from my
boyfriend I feel like it makes it kind
of weird okay alright yeah so sad he was
like now I know what I'm getting you for
Valentine's Day and sent me that message
Oh sweetheart if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and Lauren God has a channel too
I do you should check out her channel a
lot of fun different things on there
yeah oh right no one's mentioned the
button in a long time oh really we don't
do that anywhere a lot of people watch
this on their phones and stuff so they
can't see the annotations like watch I'm
gonna put one up right now you have no
idea what it says mister watching any
computer but if you're on your phone
sorry why are you watching these on your
phone anyway like shouldn't you be
paying attention to what's going on
around you like connecting to people or
driving well they are connecting with us
because we're looking at the camera
that's true but that's not going to help
Oh YouTube trick oh and shoutouts will
continue so go to facebook.com slash the
real rejects shoutouts yeah Facebook
page videos gonna end right there